all right so I'm gonna get into an
outline in a sec but one thing I wanted
to mention right off the bat is
tensorflow b2 has all the power of
graphs that we had in sensor flow one
except they're massively massively
massively easier to use in tensor flow
one the name tensor flow a tensor is
basically a fancy word for an array so
the scalar is a tensor Alissa's tensor a
cube is a tensor and flow refers to a
data flow graph and in tensor flow one
you would manually define a graph and
you would execute it with a session and
this felt a little bit like
metaprogramming and this is exactly the
system you would have wanted several
years back if you were an engineer and
the challenge you faced was massively
distributed training because graphs are
great for that however as a developer or
a student or as a researcher you want
something that feels a lot more like
python and on the right you're seeing
how tensor flow tool looks basically you
can think of a tensor in a very similar
way to a numpy and the array and you can
work with them imperative lis exactly as
you would expect in Python so you no
longer need to use things like sessions
or anything like that and it works as
you would expect which is great but
that's low-level details and here's some
of the things I'd like to talk about so
this is a rough schematic of how tensor
flow to looks and tensor flow to is a
very very large system with many moving
pieces it's a whole framework for doing
machine learning and what I'd like to do
here is show you a couple of the pieces
and what some of your options are to use
it so we will start with designing
models using my favorite API of all time
which is Kerris and what's awesome in
tensor flow too and this is a really
important point there's a spectrum of
use cases and all of these are built
into the same framework and you can mix
and match as you go and what this means
is if your total novice to deep learning
you can start with something called the
sequential API which is by far the
easiest and clearest way to develop deep
learning models today and it's wonderful
you can build a stack of layers you can
call things like compile and fit and
that is 100% valid tensorflow to code it
is just as fast as any other way of
writing code
there's no downsides to it at all if
your use case falls into that bucket and
what's really important in tensorflow 2
is as is helpful to you you can
optionally scale up and complex it
using things like the functional API or
going all the way to sub classing all in
the same framework and you can mix mix
and match as you go and what this means
is when I'm teaching this for example I
can start in these really simple clear
easy ways and then what I want to write
gratings ascend from scratch I can do
that or write custom layers from scratch
I can do that it's very easy so let's
take a look at one what some of these
pieces look like and I only have one
slide on sequential and the reason is we
have so many tutorials on it there's an
entire book on it which I'll recommend
at the end so I have just one slide on
this but in case you're new to this the
sequential API lets you define a stack
of layers and this is by far the most
common way to build your models and
something like you know I'd say 80 to
90% of machine learning models will fit
into this framework so you define a
stack of models and that's great well
it's interesting is when you're using
the sequential API and the functional
although a lot of developers don't
realize this what you're actually doing
is defining a data structure and this
means you can do things like model dot
summary and see a printout of all the
layers and all the weights it also means
that we can do compile time checks so
when you call model dot compile you can
make sure all your layers are compatible
it also means that when you share your
model with other people for example
imagine that you want to do fine-tuning
for transfer learning if you have a
model that's defined with the sequential
API or the functional API because it has
a data structure of a stack of layers or
with a functional API a graph of layers
you can inspect that data structure and
you can pull layers out of it and get
the activations and you can do fine
tuning and things like that really
easily
anyway defining a stack of layers is
very common in tensorflow - this works
exactly like it does in Karis Taiyo with
the multi back-end Kerris so that's
great one thing that's also extremely
powerful that a lot of people are new to
is the functional API and the sequential
API is for building stacks the
functional API is for building DAGs or
directed graphs and I just want to show
you how powerful this is so to be honest
most of what I've been doing myself is
using either the sequential API or going
all the way to sub classing and just
write everything from scratch but I
heard a really awesome talk on the
functional API a couple weeks ago in
Montreal and I've been using it a lot
since and I love it so I just want to
show you what it can do and so I just
want to show you what a quick model
would look like for something like
visual question-answering
and a lot of the time when you start
with machine learning you spend a lot of
your time or deep learning rather you
spend a lot of your time you know
building image classifiers and doing
things like cats and dogs but we can
take a look at a slightly more
sophisticated model and this is V QA and
in V QA you're given two inputs one
you're given an image so here we have a
pair of dogs and you're given a question
in natural language and here the
question is asking what color is the dog
on the right and so to answer a question
like this you need a much much much more
sophisticated model than just an image
classifier you can still phrase this as
a classification problem and if you
google for vqa there's two really
excellent papers that will go into
detail but you can imagine you know you
have some model well let's talk about
how we would do this here we have a
model with two inputs we have an image
in a question and if you take a machine
learning course there deep learning
course rather you'll learn about the
processing images with you know
convolutional layers and max pooling
layers and you learn about processing
text with things like LST M's and
embeddings and one thing that's really
powerful about deep learning is all of
these layers regardless of what they are
they take vectors as input and if you're
a dense layer you don't care if your
input happens to be the output of some
convolutional layer or your input
happens to the output of some LST m it's
just numbers that you're taking as input
so in deep learning there's no reason
that we can't process the image with the
CNN process the text with an LST m and
then concatenate the result and feed
that into a dense layer and phrase this
as a classification problem so you can
imagine the output of our dense layer
might have a thousand different classes
and each class corresponds to one
possible answer so here if the answer is
golden we want to classify both of these
inputs jointly as golden and I want to
show you how quickly we can design
something like this with the functional
API which is really amazing so cool it
probably should have flipped to this
slide but this is what I was just
talking through so this is the
architecture that we want we want this
is one model and it's going to have two
heads and the first head is going to be
a standard stack of CN NS and max
pulling layers and this is exactly the
same model you would use to classify
cats and dogs and you can do all the
same tricks that you will learn about
there you can import like here I want to
show you how to write it
but there's no reason that you couldn't
import like mobile Medvedev is but
basically we're gonna go from an image
to a vector and in the other head we're
gonna process the question and we're
gonna go from a question to a vector and
to do that we use an embedding in an LS
TM at the end we can catenate the
results and classify it and this is
nearly the complete code for this entire
vqa model actually it is the complete
code for the model a hello world version
of it which is nuts when you look at it
so here this is our image classifier and
you would want something much deeper but
this would be your hello world image
classifier so a vector is gonna go in
and just some like random tips I can see
my slides that's cool so you'll notice
in the first layer this is a
convolutional layer it has 64 filters
each of which is 3 by 3 and it has reimu
activation and you see in the input
shape there i'm specifying how large my
images although you'll find that Kaos
can often infer the input shape whenever
you can you should specify it and it's
just one less thing that can go wrong so
fully specify it catch bugs early after
that we're doing max pooling and the
important part is we're flattening it so
that's actually a sequential model that
we're using inside the functional API
after that we're creating an input layer
and this is for the functional API and
we're beginning to chain layers together
to build up a graph so here what we're
doing is we're chaining the vision model
to the input layer so that's the first
half of our model and here's the second
half and we're almost done so this is
the model that's going to process the
question here we're creating another
input and I don't have the
pre-processing here but you can imagine
that we've tokenized the text and we
vectorized it
we've padded it and then what we're
doing is we're feeding that into an
embedding and then into an LS TM and
this is exactly what you might do if
you're training a text classifier the
important thing is that a vector is
coming out and we're chaining these
together to build a graph and at the
very end and this is the magic bit about
deep learning we can simply concatenate
the results nothing simple but it's it's
one line of code which is nice nothing
simple conceptually but what we can do
is we can keep catenate the results and
now we just have a vector and just like
any other problem now that we have this
vector we can feed it into dense layers
and we can classify it
and so here's the tale of our model and
now we have a tensor flow to model that
will do vqa and this will work exactly
like any other chaos model so if you
want you can call model dot fit on this
thing you can call a model train on
batch you can use callbacks if you want
you can write a custom training with
using gradient tapes and so I think this
is really powerful and what's nice about
these functional API is just like
sequential models because there's a data
structure behind the scenes there's a
graph tensorflow 2 can run compatibility
checks and make sure your layers work
with each other so it's really really
nice so basically if you haven't used
the functional API either you just
learned about Carroll sequential from a
lot of books or you're coming from PI
torch and you've only used things like
sub classing I really encourage you to
try it out I've had only positive
results in the last a few weeks so I
love it
other things of course so that graph I
just made in Google slides but because
you have a data structure instead of
calling something like model summary you
can call model plot model and you'll
actually get a nice rendering of a graph
that looks exactly like what I just
showed you
so for complicated models so this is
this is cool the only time I found it
really useful is when you have
complicated models things like rez nets
you can actually plot out the whole
graph and just make sure that it looks
as you expect as you're assembling it so
it's really nice anyway and then there's
another style and tensorflow tubes so
the last two things I showed you were
built into what you'll find at Kerr
osteo
and that's multi back-end Charis Charis
is in tensorflow
- is a superset of what you find at Kerr
osteo and this is something that's new
so this is subclassing and this is a
chain or /pi torch style of developing
models which is also really really nice
and basically you'll see this little
spectrum here you're getting increasing
control as you move up and so in this
style you can be a researcher or a
student learning this for the first time
but what you're saying is I just want to
write everything from scratch to learn
how it works or because I have some
special use case that doesn't fit into
the other ones so here what we're doing
is we're defining a subclass model and I
also really love this this feels a lot
like object-oriented numpy development
so what we're doing and the idea is
basically it's very very similar in all
these frameworks the framework gives you
a class and here this class happens to
be modeled and
two chunks to writing a subclass model
you have the constructor and the call
method or the forward method or the
predict method and in the constructor
you define your layers so here I'm
creating a pair of dense layers and it's
the exact same layers that you find in
sequential and functional model api's
which is great so basically you learn
these layers once you can use them all
over the place and in the call method or
the forward method you describe how
these layers are chained together so
here I have some inputs and I'm feeding
the inputs through my dense layer and
then I'm feeding that result through my
second dense layer and returning it and
what's nice is this is not symbolic so
if you're curious what X is you can just
do print X of course like you wouldn't
python and that will give you the
activations of that first dense layer if
you want you can modify it so for
example here I've highlighted ray Lew
let's say for some reason I'm not
interested in using the built in ray Lew
activation I want to write my own what
you can do simply is just remove that
and you can write your own with just
regular Python flow right there so there
I've written ray Lew using the built-in
method but I could also just write that
using regular Python so this is great
for hacking on things it's great if you
want to really know the details of what
exactly is flowing in and out of these
layers it's a perfect way to do it also
for example there's nothing here that's
saying that you have to use these
built-in dense layers so if you look at
the code from the dense layer that's
doing something like W X plus B you can
absolutely just write that from scratch
in in Python and use that here instead
and then these are just a whole bunch of
references I'm gonna tweet out these
slides when we finish so you don't have
to write it down but what these are
these are guides from tensorflow to that
we'll go into detail on how you write
how do you use each of these three
styles of the Charis api how do you
write custom layers and stuff like that
they're great and then we have a couple
tutorials that I recommend that it
really really nice that showed different
ways of building stuff if you haven't
seen these by the way the segmentation
one is super nice we wrote it this
summer it runs really really fast and I
think you'll like it also by the way
because this is an intro to tensor flow
to talk let me just show you what the
tutorials are in case you're new to
these and there's just one thing I want
to point out so this is a tutorial on a
website big surprise
what I wanted to mention and I think
this is a really nice feature of tensor
flow org obviously this is the webpage
HTML but this is just a direct rendering
of this Jupiter notebook so the web page
is just the Jupiter notebook and the
reason we've done that is all the
tutorials are runnable end to end so you
can install tensor flow to locally and
run this tutorial or if you click run in
collab this is exactly the same page as
you have on tensor flow dat org for all
of these you can do runtime run all and
this has the complete code to reproduce
the results that you see here and what
this means is that our tutorials are
testable and you know the expression of
trust but verify so for a long time I've
seen like nifty tutorials that are like
yeah like let me show you how to write
this like your own machine translation
model and then the code doesn't work or
it's missing you know a key piece that's
left as an exercise to the reader so at
least all the tutorials on the website
all of them run and end which is really
really nice some we still have plenty of
work to do cleaning them up but at least
they guarantee you they have the
complete code to do this thing so I
really like that a lot
alright I wanted to talk a little bit
about training models and so basically
there are several ways to train models
and again you can use the nice thing
about tensorflow too is you can use the
one that's most helpful for your use
case so you don't always need to write a
custom training loop from scratch so you
have other options and the first is that
you might be from
with from Karros is just simply calling
model dot fit and what's really nice
about model dot fit this doesn't it
doesn't care if you have a sequential
model a functional model or subclass
model it works for all of them and model
dot fit it's fast its performing it's
simple one thing that's a little bit
less obvious when you do modeled outfit
this is not just the baby way of
training models so if you're working in
a team and you call model dot fit you've
reduced your code footprint by a lot
this is one less thing that your friends
and need to worry about when they're
playing with your models down the road
so if you can use the simple things you
should unless there's a reason for more
complexity of course just like in
regular software engineering the nice
thing about fit is you can pass in
different metrics and a lot of examples
you'll see things like accuracy by the
way tensorflow 2 has really nice metrics
for things like precision and recall
built-in you can also write custom
metrics and something that's really
helpful too is callbacks so for instance
these are things that I don't see a lot
of new developers using and they're
super helpful
so callbacks and one of my favorites is
early stopping and so typically you know
when we're training models we need to
prevent overfitting and a really
wonderful way to do that is to make
plots of your you know loss over time
and so on and so forth these callbacks
can do things like that for you
automatically which can be helpful as
well you can also write custom callbacks
so a cool thing would be like let's say
you're taking your training a model that
takes very long time to train you could
write a callback to send you a slack
notification after every epoch of
training completes and so that can be
really nifty too so callbacks are great
and then I don't have show slides for
train on batch here but I did want to
show you custom training with the
gradient tape because this is also very
powerful especially for students who are
learning this for the first time and
don't want a black box or for
researchers and so here's a custom
training loop and I have an example this
for you in a minute
just with linear regressions so you can
see exactly how this works but this is a
custom training loop and what we're
doing here is we have some function and
for now you can pretend that at TF
function in the orange box doesn't exist
so that's optional so just pretend that
doesn't exist we have some function
that's taking features and labels as
input and whenever we're doing training
in deep learning we're doing gradient
descent the first step in doing gradient
descent is getting the gradients and the
way all frameworks do this is by back
prop which is reverse mode auto-da-fé
and the implementation in tensorflow is
we start recording operations on a tape
so here we're creating a tape and we're
recording what's happening beneath that
tape so we have just regular Python code
that's calling the forward method or the
call method rather on your model so we
afford the features through a model then
we're computing some loss and maybe
we're doing regression that's squared
error and then what we're doing is we're
getting the gradients of the loss with
respect to all the variables in the
model and if you print those out you'll
see exactly what the gradients are and
then here we're doing gradient descent
manually we're applying them on an
optimizer we can also write our own
optimizer and I'll show you that in a
second anyway this is a custom training
loop from scratch and what this means is
that if you so in model dot fit you can
use optimizers like rmsprop and adam and
all this stuff but if you'd like to
write like the Serra optimizer you can
go ahead and write it in Python and they
will fit right in with your model so
this is great for research TF function
by the way first of all you never need
to write it your code will work the same
but if you do want a graph in tensorflow
- or if you will basically if you want
to compile your code and have it run
faster you can write that TF function
annotation and what this means is that
tensorflow two will trace your
computation compile it and the second
and on time that you run this function
it will be much much much faster because
it's running entirely in C++ so all the
wrister graphs in tensorflow - is
basically at TF function
but it's optional you don't even need to
use it but it's easy performance if you
need it and then I just want to make
this super concrete because this is
getting started with tensorflow to talk
the there's a lot of awesome tutorials
that will quickly show you on the
website how to train you know image
classifiers and whatnot but I think a
good place to start too is just looking
at linear regression and the reason is
it's gradient descent all deep neural
networks are trained by gradient descent
and a nice place to start is seeing
exactly what that is and because I have
I know it's tiny but because I have a
graphic here on the Left I'm just
briefly going to explain how linear
regression works and it's the same it's
the same pattern for deep neural
networks too which is really surprising
so in linear regression or deep neural
networks you need three things the first
thing you need is a model which is a
function that makes a prediction and so
a model for linear regression that you
might have learned in high school could
be y equals MX plus B we're trying to
find the best fit line and we can define
a line y equals MX plus B that means we
have two parameters or variables that we
need to set we have M which is the slope
right and we have B which is the
intercept and by wiggling those
variables we can fit the line to our
data so on the right you'll see a plot
and we have like a scatter plot with a
bunch of points and we have the best fit
line and the idea is now that we have a
model or a line that we can wiggle we
need a way of saying or quantifying how
well does this line fit the data one way
to quantify how well the line fits the
data is squared error what that means is
you drop a line on the page and then you
measure the distance from your line to
all the points and you take the sum of
the squares of that the higher the sum
of the squares is the farther the worse
your line fits the data the better your
line fits the data the lower the sum of
the squares so you can have a single
number which is called loss that
describes how badly your line fits the
data and then you want to reduce that
loss and you know that if the loss gets
to a minimum your line will fit the data
well and you found the best fit line the
way we reduce the loss is gradient
descent
and on the Left you'll see a grading
descent plot and we're looking at loss
or a squared error as a function of two
variables M and B and you can see that
if we set M&V with a random guess to
start our loss is pretty high and then
as we wiggle them we can reduce the loss
the trick is how do we figure out which
way to wiggle m and B and briefly I
don't want to go in too much of a
tangent there's two ways to do that
if you forget calculus you can find the
gradient numerically and it's not rocket
science you take em and you wiggle it up
a little bit recompute your loss
then you take em and you wiggle it down
a little bit and you recompute your loss
you figure out which way makes the loss
go down that's that's the direction
you're gonna be wiggling ya do the same
thing for B that's very very slow and
there's faster ways to do it too but I
want to show you what this code looks
like in tensorflow 2 so basically you
don't have to use chaos at all you can
also use tensor flow to a lot like you
would use numpy and basically whenever
you see something like tensor just
replace that your head with numpy MD
array so we have constants and you see
if you print out a constant it has a
shape and a data type one really nice
thing about tensor flow tensors they
have a numpy method so you can go
straight from tensors to numpy which is
great so you're really free of the
clutches and tensor flow to tensors have
a shape and a datatype and then just
like you would expect a numpy we have
things like distributions so if you want
to create some you know random normal
here's how you would do it just one
flight it's really quick and you can do
math and tensor flow to a lot like you
would do math and numpy so basically
just like you have things like numpy dot
square and um pi that matrix multiply
tensorflow has all these same things too
and the idea is the same the names might
be slightly different you might have to
poke around a little bit but the names
are all there and here's an example of
like very very simple here's how we get
the gradients using the gradient tape
but this is more concrete so here we
have a constant that's three and we have
a function which is x squared and so if
you think about your rules of calculus
if we have you know three x squared then
you take the two and you multiply it by
the three and you get six and if you
walk through this code you'll see that
it returns you 6 2 so basically this is
how we get the gradient gradient
and you can also do that with all the
variables and layers at once so here we
have a pair of dense layers and we're
calling the dense layers on some data
and we're getting the gradients also
under the table and let me just show you
what this looks like in linear
regression just to make this concrete so
this is code for y equals MX plus B and
the first thing I wanted to mention is
how you install tensorflow too if you're
running in collab right now in collab
tensorflow one is installed by default
but there's a magic flag you can run so
that magic command will give you the
latest version of tensorflow 2 if you're
running this locally you can visit
tensorflow dat org slash install and you
can do pip install tensorflow
so anything you can call a bu locally
but I have this here this is convenient
tensorflow is just a python library you
can port it import it as you always
would and the first thing we do in this
notebook i know i flew through some of
those code examples but what we're going
to do is just create a scatter plot so
just some random data and then we're
going to find the best fit line so here
what we're doing is we're creating some
data let me see if I've run this before
yeah
and then we're plotting the data and
here's what we get the slides had
tensorflow constants and these are
tensor flow variables and basically
constants are constant and variables can
be adjusted over time you almost never
need to write code this low-level this
is pretending that we don't have chaos
we don't have any of these built-in fit
methods we just want to do this from
scratch but here's how you would do it
from scratch so I'm creating some
variables here I've initialized them to
zero I probably should have initialized
them to a random number but this will
work too and then here this doesn't look
scary at all this is the predict
function for linear regression so this
is our equation for a line y equals MX
plus B and our goal is going to be to
find good values for M and B here's our
loss function and what we're doing is
we're taking the results that we
predicted minus the results that we
wanted we're squaring it and we're
taking the average so that's squared
error
and then as we go through this notebook
we can see our squared error when we
start
and here's gradient descent from scratch
pretending that we didn't have anything
like model dot fit so for some number of
steps what we're doing is we're taking
our X's and we're forwarding to through
the model to predict their Y's we're
getting the squared error which is a
single number and then we're getting the
gradients of M and B with respect to the
loss and this will literally tell us if
you print those out those are just
numbers and the gradients point in the
direction of steepest ascent so if we
move in the direction of gradients or
loss will increase we want the loss to
decrease so we remove we move in the
reverse direction of the gradients which
is gradient descent and here again this
is like the lowest possible level way to
write this code we're doing gradient
descent from scratch so we don't have
any optimizer what we're doing is we're
taking a step in the negative gradient
multiplied by a learning rate and that
adjusts M and B as we go and if you run
this code you'll see the loss is
decreasing and you'll see the final
values for M and B and plot the best fit
line and then what I did for you is I
wrote this is a little bit uglier but I
wrote some code to produce this diagram
just so you can see exactly what the
gradient descent is doing so that's how
you would write things from scratch and
tensorflow too and what's really really
awesome when you move to things like
neural networks this code is basically
copy and pasted so if you can compare
this custom training loop for linear
regression to the custom training loop
or d3 or any of the fancy models on the
website it looks almost identical you
always have this tape and the steps are
the same you make a prediction you get
your loss you get the gradients and you
go from there so that's really nice
alright other things I wanted to mention
I got to move a lot faster here
so in terms of datasets basically you
have two options in tensorflow - the
first option is at the top and these are
all the existing Kaos datasets that you
find at Kaos dot IO and these are great
they're good to start with they're numpy
format and they're usually really tiny
they fit into memory no problem then we
have this enormous collection of
research datasets which is awesome and
that's called tensor flow datasets and
here I'm showing you how you can
download something like cycle Ganon
tensorflow datasets what's important to
be aware of I just have a couple quick
tips if you're downloading a dataset and
tensor flow data format by the way it's
going to give you something called the
datasets not going to be an umpire it's
gonna be in TF data and TF data it's a
high performance format for data it's
slightly trickier to use than what you
might be used to and so if you're using
tensor flow datasets you have to be very
very careful to benchmark your input
pipeline if you just import a data set
and try and call model dot fit on the
data set it might be slow so it's
important to take your time and make
sure that your data pipeline can read
images off disk and things like that
efficiently I have just a couple tips
that might be helpful tensorflow data
sets recently added an in-memory flag so
if you don't want to write fast input
pipelines you can pass in memory and you
can slurp the whole thing into RAM so
that will make it really easy and it
also added this caching function which
is really really nice so here's some
code for TF data and maybe we have an
image data set and we have some code to
pre process the images and let's pretend
that pre-processing code is expensive
and we don't want to run it every time
we need to run every app hoc what you
can do is you can add this cache line at
the end cache will keep the results of
the pre-processing in memory and will
make subsequent runs of your pipeline
much faster so cache is a really handy
thing to be aware of the goal here is
not to give you all the details for this
it's just to point you to some things
that are useful to know about you can
also cache to files so cache without any
parameters will cache it into RAM if you
pass a file name you can actually cache
it to a file on disk too
one thing that's awesome in tensorflow
to that you if you're an expert you'll
care about it and if not you'll care
about down the road is distributed
training and I'm gonna skip some slides
to move faster what I wanted to say
briefly is distributed training in
tensorflow - is awesome and it's awesome
because if you're doing single machine
multiple GPU synchronous their data
parallel training or you're doing multi
machine multi-gpu synchronous data
parallel training you don't need to
change the code of your model which is
exactly what I care about
and so it's awesome and basically here
is some chaos model this happens to be a
built-in application for ResNet but it
doesn't matter and I just want to show
you how we run this code on one machine
with multiple GPUs we just wrap it in a
block that's it and model dot fit is
distribute aware and will work so you
don't need to change your model to run
on multiple GPUs and this particular
strategy is called a mirrored strategy
there's different strategies you can use
this tribute mult year models there's
another strategy
it's like mirrored multi worker which
you can change that one line and then if
you have network with multiple machines
on it again your code doesn't change so
that's awesome I really really like the
design of this alright all the things
that are awesome about tensorflow to
that I'd really encourage you to check
out especially if you're learning or you
have students is going beyond Python so
we've talked about training models and
care offs and I just want to show you
some of the cool things you can do to
deploy them and roughly there's a bunch
of different ways that you can deploy
your models the way that I was used to a
few years ago as a Python developer was
I throw up a REST API and I can do that
using like ten servos serving or flask
or whatever you want and I serve the
thing behind an API cuz that's what I
know how to do there's a couple things
that I've been learning since then which
have been great and that's basically
deploying models in the browser with
tensorflow j/s deploying them on Android
and iOS using tensorflow light and very
recently running them on Arduino using
tensorflow light micro and I have a
couple suggested projects for you that I
just wanted to point you to so the first
is its tiny ml and this was a blog post
this was a guest article on our blog a
few week
by the arduino team and this article is
basically a tutorial and what we're
looking at is an Arduino it's a
microcontroller and if you're new to
microcontrollers it's a system on a chip
but it also has pins that it can run
voltage to a read voltage from and so
for instance you can plug an LED light
bulb into one of those pins and you can
have C code which runs voltage to the
pin and turns on the light likewise you
could have an accelerometer attached to
one of the pins and you could have C
code that reads from the accelerometer
and gives you some time series data so
that's what a microcontroller is it's a
computer plus these basically pins that
you can read and write to tensorflow
light is the code we use to deploy
tensorflow models onto phones but
recently tensorflow light micro now lets
you deploy them onto arduino and these
things are smaller than a stick of gum
this is a really nice one it has this is
a nano that has built-in sensors I have
one at home but it's still about 30
bucks and it has a built-in
accelerometer or a temperature sensor
stuff like that but anyway what we're
looking at here this is a demo using the
accelerometer someone trained a model to
recognize to gestures one it's like a
punch in what is an uppercut and you can
see they're holding your Arduino in
their hand and as they're moving it the
laptop is recognizing the gestures but
the workflow and this is in the blog
post is not bad at all considering how
much power you're getting out of it so
what you're doing and let me see if I
can just show you the steps basically
the first thing you need to do is
capture data and I wanted to bring it
Arduino with me I thought it'll be
better just to quickly show you these
gifts but you can plug the Arduino into
your laptop with a USB cable you need to
collect training data for your model so
what you do is you hold the Arduino in
your hand and you collect a bunch of
data for your punching gesture and you
say that two-disc is a time series and
the diagram on the right there I was
just capturing the IDE this morning as
you move the accelerator as you move the
Arduino around you're reading from the
accelerometer and what you get out is
just a CSV file with time series data
exactly like you would have if you were
looking through the
timeseriesforecasting tutorial on
tensorflow at org and you can do the
same thing for your other gestures so
what you do is you gather data you save
CSV files you upload them to collab
in collab you write a model using
tensorflow 2 and care us to classify the
data and that's just a regular Python
model you don't need to know anything
special about tensorflow light to do it
and then what I wanted to show you and
you can find a complete code in the blog
post there's a very small amount of code
that you need to convert your model from
Python down into tensorflow light format
to run on device and this is a tiny
amount of code once you have this model
and this is a little unusual it's we're
gonna convert it to a c array and that's
because this arduino it has like one
megabyte of disk space and i think like
256 kb of ram so we're converting it
into the smallest simplest possible
format but you convert it to a C or a
and then what you can do we have an
example and you can paste the C array
into the example and now you're running
your your tensorflow model on device and
it's amazing like that's so much fun
doing this the reason I wanted to point
it to you if you have kids or you've
students that want to play with this
stuff if if you teach them just to train
a time series forecasting model which is
a really valuable skill we've a pretty
good tutorial for it I mean it's
interesting but it's vastly more
interesting if they can then deploy it
on device it gives them something
tangible that they can play with and
show their friends it's super cool also
this is a brand new area so tiny ml
referring to doing machine learning on
small devices I think there's a lot of
promise another way to deploy your
models which is super powerful is in
JavaScript and this is using tensorflow
j/s here's another project suggestion
one of the first tutorials you might run
through in deep learning is sentiment
analysis so given a sentence predict if
it's positive or negative also a really
valuable skill can be somewhat dry right
but the first time I've ever been super
excited about sentiment analysis other
than many years ago when I found out I
can make money for it that was not the
link that I wanted if you go into this
game repo link from the slides you will
find
that you can run ten sentiment analysis
live in JavaScript so for example this
is just a web page and down at the
bottom here the movie was awesome so I
wrote a sentence and you can see that's
predicted positive and here you can see
that's predicted negative and what's
nice about doing javascript in the
browser from the user perspective is
there's nothing to install which means
if you're a Python developer and your
goal is to have a cool demo instead of
throwing up a REST API you can create a
webpage and share it with your friends
and what's nice this model was written
in tensorflow to using Karos and we have
a converter script that will convert it
into tensorflow JS format to run in the
browser so following examples I am NOT a
JavaScript developer at all I can get
through the examples and it's not too
bad so it's possible to do but it's a
really good opportunity if you have
friends that are good JavaScript
developers this is a huge collaboration
opportunity where you can develop models
and your friends can help you deploy
them in the browser also if you haven't
seen it you can also write models from
scratch in JavaScript and I just wanted
to show you a couple demos here
I'm almost certainly gonna accidentally
unplug this laptop but another super
convincing thing about why you might
want to do javascript in the browser
this is a model called pose net this
could be the end of the presentation
this is a model called pose net it's
running entirely client-side in the
browser so nothing's being sent to a
server and it's not meant for this many
people but you can see that it's
starting to recognize where people are
in the audience and what's cool I know
this is all obvious for web developers
but I'm not so this is all new to me for
me to do this in Python would have been
a nightmare like I would have to be
streaming data from the video camera
sending it to a server classifying it
server-side sending the results back
there's no way I'd be able to do that in
real time like that also for privacy
reasons that would not be cool but
because uh this is running client-side
in JavaScript we can do that and so
immediately like you can you can see all
the things that we can do on top of this
there's other models like that too that
are just really compelling
and then for people looking for
applications
so there's sentiment analysis but a
model built right on top of that in the
browser is just text classification but
this is multi class text classification
and this is a toxicity detector
it's basically sentiment analysis model
but the idea is you're given a sentence
and you want to figure out if this is
like a comment that you might want to
post on YouTube or something like this
but you can build tools like this that
analyze text privately quickly
client-side so you can imagine for
example if you had a job as like a
wicked wikimedia moderator and you
wanted to take a look at article edits
to see if they were something you wanted
to publish or not you might spend a lot
of your time looking for toxic comments
with something like this you could very
quickly pre-process you can immediately
have code that right in the web page
highlights the bad parts of the article
and I need to move a little bit quicker
so let me just point you to one demo and
it'll stop if you're new to temp to flow
just by far the best demo there's two
and they're right here one is Poe's net
which you can get at that link there's
also a pac-man if you haven't seen
pac-man you can control pac-man with
your face you can train a model live in
the browser to do that which is awesome
and then flying through this last
comment then learning more if you're
working in collab and you're used to
using chaos what you don't want to do is
import Karros you want to say from
tensorflow
ecord Karros and that will give you the
version of Kaos intenser glow - that's a
super set of regular chaos this is only
a problem in collab because chaos is
installed there by default if you ever
see a message it says using tensorflow
back-end you've imported the wrong
version to Kaos and then last slide here
are four books that I'd recommend the
first the very first book is about
tensorflow - and this will give you
low-level details it's great only by the
second edition the first edition teaches
tensorflow one which you do not need to
learn how to use to use tensorflow - the
second book doesn't mention the word
tensorflow at all that's the chaos book
by Francois Sholay but it's outstanding
if you're new to deep learning it's a
perfectly good place to start all the
code from the second book will also work
inside tensorflow - just by saying from
tensorflow import chaos nothing else
will change it's all completely good the
next book is Karros in JavaScript so
deep flirting with JavaScript which is
great the fourth book is brand new
that's by Pete worden tiny ml so thanks
very much and I'll stop there don't be
around after 4 questions
[Applause]
I'll be right outside we're standing in
the back there's some more seats over on
this side of the room we'll be back in
about ten minutes see you soon
you